The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: [INAUDIBLE]
theory graphs calculating
the effective
theory graphs using
the same infrared regulator,
renormalizing each of them
separately, and then
subtracting them
to figure out higher-order
corrections to the Wilson
coefficients.
And as part of that
discussion, we also
talked about scheme
dependence because when
you do that procedure
for normalization
in the effective theory, you're
making a choice for the scheme.
We picked m s bar, but you
could pick other choices.
And at the end of lecture,
we talked about the fact
that when you make
different scheme choices,
it can affect things.
So it can affect the
Wilson coefficients.
It'll affect the matrix
elements of operators.
It'll affect your
matching coefficients
at one loop and your anomalous
dimensions at two loops,
but those scheme dependencies
cancel out in observables.
So it's important to take the
scheme into account and work
in the same scheme.
But if you consistently use
the same scheme for everything,
then you will be OK.
Now, if you're just doing
calculations on pen and paper,
it's very easy that
you just-- well, we
love the m s bar scheme.
Let's use that.
But remember that
sometimes, there
will be things in
your result that you
may want to get from elsewhere.
For example, maybe there's
some matrix elements
of the operators.
You want to get them
from the lattice.
Well, if you look up
results in a lattice,
they're not using m s bar.
There's no non-perturbative
definition of m s bar.
So they'll be using
some other scheme.
And those results will
have to be converted
to m s bar if you're
going to put them together
with your results.
So that's just something
to be aware of.
Before we leave this topic
and go on to something else,
I thought I'd say a few
words about phenomenology.
What is all this
technology good for?
So a nice example of
that is beta s gamma.
So beta s gamma--
it's a neutral current process.
It doesn't happen in the
Steiner model at tree level.
And therefore, what that
means, if it doesn't
happen at tree
level, is that it's
sensitive to loop corrections.
And you could go--
since we talked about a
channel with b to c, you bar d,
but this is very analogous.
We have a b meson in
the initial-- b quark
in the initial state.
So it's the same
scales in the problem.
Effectively, the b quark
scale is the light scale.
We want to get rid
of the things that
would mediate this decay that
are inside the loop, which
will be w bosons and top
quarks in this example.
And so you draw this
in the standard model.
There's various diagrams
that contribute.
One is this one.
So here's a b quark changing
into a strange quark
through a top quark and a w.
And if we integrate
out the w in the top,
then we get some local
operator, much as
we were talking about
in our examples up here.
It's just that we have
different diagrams.
And we can also, from the
low-energy point of view,
enumerate the operators.
For some reason, I started
calling it Q instead of O.
Let me give you an example
of some of these operators.
So here's what you would
call a magnetic dipole
operator, couples directly
to the photon, which
is in the F mu nu.
And it takes the b to an s bar.
And that's an example of a
higher dimension operator.
Remember, this is
dimension 2 and then plus 3
there, so that's 5.
There's a factor of the b
quark mass that just comes in
because of the chiral structure
of the operator, which
you can think of as there needs
to be a mass insertion here.
You need one factor of that
mass in order for the diagram
not to give 0.
If you really start
to do beta s gamma,
and you want to go
through the whole story,
then you have to actually
think about other operators.
And there's a whole
basis of them.
And one thing you
could do is you
could take the operator
up there and just
replace the photon by a gluon.
That won't give a tree-level
contribution to beta s gamma,
but these guys are charged
under electromagnetism.
So you could just
have a direct coupling
to the b quark or
the strange quark,
and then loop up the
gluon, and get a correction
from an operator like this one.
And then there's also
four quark operators,
like the ones we
talked about before,
but with different flavors.
And if you enumerate
all of them,
there's nine more different ways
of making four-quark operators.
So you could build some basis
using the equation of motion
to simplify the operators
as much as possible.
And then you get
down to these ones.
And you can go
through the program
that we talked about, of doing
matching and renormalizations
with evolution.
And really what I want
to talk about here
is a little bit
about phenomenology,
because the interesting
thing about this loop
is that if there was
nu physics-- since
in the standard model at
tree level it doesn't happen,
if there's nu physics, then
you can be sensitive to it
here, because you're
sensitive to heavy particles
in this loop.
That's why beta
s gamma is always
used to constrain nu physics.
So in our effective theory, we
have just an operator that does
this, which is this 07 gamma.
And if you think about what
C 7 gamma is at lowest order,
let's just calculate
that diagram over there.
And the result from
doing that will
be some function
of m w over m top,
because those are the things
that are appearing in the loop.
And if you do that calculation,
you get a number like that,
if you stick values
for the top m w.
And then you can start
doing loop corrections.
The first thing you
might think about,
which is actually
not even suppressed
by any factors of the
coupling alpha s strong,
would be to just loop up the Q1
operator, which I guess I don't
know why I wrote it this way.
This should be b.
You could just loop the Q1
operator, contract the u u var,
and then you can get a beta s
transition from this operator.
So this is the u quark here,
and then attach a photon.
And there's no factor in that
loop of the strong coupling,
because this is an
electromagnetic coupling,
and this guy here is
just this Q1 operator.
So this doesn't look like
it's loop suppressed relative
to that.
And this is a little subtle,
but this guy actually is 0.
So you have to use a
good scheme for gamma 5,
but it turns out to be 0.
So the first type of loop
corrections that you get,
which are suppressed
by a factor of alpha s,
come from diagrams like--
well, there's various
diagrams, but one of them
is like this, where I take
the same diagram there
and I attach an extra
gluon on top of it.
This guy diverges.
And this two-loop calculation
is order alpha strong,
and it gives the leading
order anomalous dimension,
what we were calling gamma 0.
It's not the only diagram.
There's other diagrams, too.
So we could go through that and
do the similar type of thing,
just with more diagrams
than we had in our example.
In particular, we
could construct
from the tree level matching
in the one-loop anomalous
dimension, the leading
log result. Let me
just write that down for you.
Putting in numbers for the
anomalous dimensions, at least
sometimes putting
in numbers for them.
So the eta factor here
is the ratio of alphas.
So this is similar to what
we saw before in our example
where we got a ratio of
alphas raised to a power.
And if you want to pick a mu
for this process over here,
beta s gamma, then the right
mu to think about is m b.
So we want to take
mu to the m b.
And so if I plug in numbers--
and this is really what
I wanted to emphasize--
if I plug in numbers here
for these various things,
this guy here gives
a factor of 0.7.
This guy here is this minus 0.2
that we talked about up there.
This factor here is
a bit small, 0.085.
0.96.
That's right.
And then this piece here is
a substantial correction.
And if I wrote down all
these numbers correctly,
then the final result
comes out to be,
if I keep three digits,
minus 0.3, which you can see
is a fairly substantial
change from minus 0.2.
It's a 50% change.
So just taking into
account the evolution
gives a 50% correction.
So if you didn't take it into
account, and you just said,
well, forget about
effective theory.
I just calculate this graph.
That's the standard model, you'd
think that there is nu physics.
We've certainly tested beta
s gamma at better than 50%,
more like the 10% level.
So you really have to take
into account these effects
that we've been talking
about, like this leading log
evolution, if you want to look
for nu physics, because you've
got to get the right standard
model result. 50% larger.
And actually, people go
two orders beyond what
I'm talking about here.
They go to the next, the
next leading log order,
when they really do precision
beta s gamma physics.
So some of the state of the
art calculations of multiloop
diagrams have been done
exactly for beta s gamma
because these effects are
so important for looking
for nu physics.
And it's even worse
when you get it put it
in the branching ratio, because
a 50% enhancement in a coupling
when you put it in
the branching ratio,
you're squaring the amplitude.
So that's a factor of 2.3.
So these are really
crucial corrections
to take into account.
So that's what this electroweak
Hamiltonian is actually used
for when you do phenomenology.
So that's what I wanted to
say about the electroweak
Hamiltonian, just to
give you a flavor for it.
There's lots more that
you could do with it.
We could talk about
more phenomenology,
but let me stop there,
since the idea is
to give you an introduction
to the concepts
and we've done that.
So now we'll move on
to something else,
which is a different concept,
unless there's any questions.
So all this business
of schemes and stuff
comes in when people are
talking about beta s gamma
and making this kind
of model prediction.
And there's actually schemes
you can pick where you mess this
up, but then, if
you're careful, you
get the same answer
in the very end.
So the next topic that
I want to talk about
is an example of
something that's bottom up
effective field theory.
We've talked about top
down with this example
of removing heavy particles.
And the classic
example of bottom
up is chiral perturbation
theory or chiral Lagrangians.
So our purposes here are not--
again, they're not
a full exploration
of this topic, which
is a very large topic.
So what are our goals?
Bottom up effective
theory example.
We will also see in
this example the utility
of using something that's
called the nonlinear
realization of symmetry,
non-linear symmetry
representations, and
the kind of connection
to field redefinitions.
Since field redefinitions
is something
we've been talking about,
we'll talk about that.
Another thing that
this is an example of
is an example where loops are
not suppressed by the coupling
constant.
Instead, they're actually
suppressed by powers
in the power expansion.
So that's kind of totally
different than what
we saw when we were integrating
all the heavy particles,
where you just put a loop.
You're down by some
factor of alpha s,
but you're at the same
order in the power expansion
and 1 over large scale.
This is going to be different.
And therefore, in some ways
this has a non-trivial power
accounting--
more non-trivial,
anyway, than what
we were just talking about.
So we'd like to give this as
an example of non-trivial power
accounting, and in fact,
prove something that's called
a "power accounting theorem."
What the power
accounting theorem
means is that ahead
of time, you should
be able to figure out from
your effective theory what
order various things are.
If you draw a
diagram, you should
know even before you calculate
it how many powers in the power
accounting expansion you have.
If you didn't know
that, you wouldn't
know which diagrams to compute
and which ones not to compute.
You'd just have to
compute them all.
That's, of course,
way too much work.
So in order to formulate
the effective theory--
especially since there's an
infinite number of diagrams.
So in order to formulate
the theory, remember,
you really have to have power
accounting under control.
And that means you need
things like this in order
to identify what's
leading order.
So we'll talk about that.
So I'm imagining that
maybe 50% of the class
has seen chiral perturbation
theory before in some form.
I know I teach it in
Quantum Field Theory 3,
so if you took QFT 3 with me,
you saw a glimpse into it.
The things we're going to
emphasize here are a bit
different, but I am going to
assume that you have knowledge
of it at some level, and I'll
assign you reading if you
don't.
The other thing
I'm going to assume
that you have some knowledge
of is spontaneous symmetry
breaking, because
that's not the topic.
That's not one of the things
that I've listed here.
That's not something that I
really want to delve into,
but of course, if we talk about
the chiral Lagrangian, that's
something that comes in,
in particular, when we're
talking about it from QCD.
So I'll remind you of some
things that are hopefully
familiar, and anything
that's unfamiliar,
you should do
additional reading on.
So I know that there
are some people that
are taking QFT 3 right now,
so this may be something
they haven't got to yet.
So I will do some review,
but for further reading,
you should see QFT 3
or some other source.
I've posted some
readings on the website.
So if we start with
QCD, massless QCD,
we can divide it into
a left-handed part
and a right-handed part.
And then we can talk
about the transformation
where we take the
left-handed field
and transform it by
a separate amount
than the right-handed field
under a unitary transformation.
And that's a symmetry
of the theory.
Now, exactly what
symmetry you have
depends on how many
components you're
talking about in the psi field.
If I say the psi field
is light, then you
might think of up and down,
and that's one possibility.
Or you could throw
the strange in there,
and say, well, the
strange is light, too,
and then you have up,
down, and strange.
And that just the difference
between SU2 and SU3,
and both of these
are viable choices.
So let's make a little table.
We have a group, which is
the transformations given
by the left and the right.
And it's going to be
broken spontaneously
to some other group.
So it could be SU3.
So there's saying that
the left and the right
are in SU3, each of them.
And in QCD, that's broken
to the vector subgroup.
So in this case, the
psi would be u d s.
And you get Goldstone
bosons from that.
And there's eight of them.
And that's the pions,
the kaon, and the eta.
And keeping thing from
our perspective what
is the expansion parameter,
and it's not so great,
because the strange quark
mass is not that light.
So you can think that the
strange quark mass over lambda
QCD is maybe something
like 1/3-ish,
but you're not really
getting better than that.
So there was 8 generations
here, 8 generators here,
broken to 8 here.
And then you have 8 Goldstones.
You could do better, but
make less predictions,
if you just considered SU2 and
just maybe up and down light.
Then you just have the pions.
And then you just have MU
and MD over lambda QCD,
which is more like 1/50,
so a much better expansion.
But then you can't
do kaon physics
with this, because
the kaon is not
part of the effective theory,
and that can be the case.
So in order to construct a
theory for the Goldstones,
which are the light
degrees of freedom--
so this is we've identified
the light degrees of freedom--
you'd like to construct an
effective theory for them.
Those are bound states
of the particles
in your original theory, and you
don't know, on pen and paper,
how to calculate the matching.
And that's characteristic of
a bottom up effective theory--
that you don't do the
matching, that you just
start from the bottom up.
So in this case, you
don't do the matching
because it's non-perturbative.
So what you do is you
say, let's construct
a type of field theory
based on the fact
that I know what the
degrees of freedom are
and I know something
about symmetry.
And in particular
in this case, you
know something about
symmetry breaking.
So one kind of logic
is, then what you'll get
is you'll get coefficients
times operators again.
The operators will be built out
of your pion/kaon/eta fields.
And you'll be able to calculate
matrix elements of these.
But you'll get some coefficients
and you don't know the value.
So these coefficients
you could fit to data,
because you haven't
determined them
from some high-level theory.
You just could fit them to
the data and do phenomenology.
So it's kind of
exactly the opposite
from our high-energy
point of view,
from the theory with the
electroweak Hamiltonian, where
we thought the
matrix elements were
going to be non-perturbative.
Here are the matrix elements.
They're something you calculate.
And the coefficients
are including
the non-perturbative physics.
You could also get
these from the lattice.
So a lattice QCD
calculation can tell you
the values for the C's to use.
And then you could just
use the chiral Lagrangian
to do phenomenology.
Now, because we have this
bottom-up point of view,
there's something
that we don't know.
And that is, we actually
don't know precisely what
theory we started
with, because all we're
encoding about that theory is
the symmetry breaking pattern.
And so if there's a bunch
of upper-level theories
that have the same
symmetry breaking pattern,
they all look the same.
They'll look like they have
the same chiral Lagrangian.
And the thing that
distinguishes them
is that they would have
different coefficients.
And you wouldn't know that
unless you figured out
what the coefficients are.
So that's another
way of just saying
that the high-energy
physics is being
encoded in the coefficients.
So the same chiral
Lagrangian would show up
for different
high-level theories
that have the same
symmetry breaking pattern.
So this is just one example
of chiral Lagrangians.
And we're going to use
it as an example, which
is perhaps the most familiar,
to illustrate our bullets.
So one of our
bullets was related
to non-linear representations
in field redefinition,
so let's start with that one.
Problems set's due today.
Problem set 2 is posted.
So let me talk about something
called the "linear sigma
model."
And we'll use this as
an example of something
that has a symmetry
breaking pattern that's
similar to the one we want,
same as the one we want.
And we'll construct, from
this, the chiral Lagrangian.
And since it's the same
symmetry breaking pattern,
it's also a viable chiral
Lagrangian directly for QCD.
So what is the
linear sigma model?
So I'll talk about
fields that I call pi
without a vector symbol on top.
They have two components.
One component that's in the
diagonal, then one component--
these are matrices
in the off diagonal,
and different entries
in the sigma 3.
So I want to think of this
is a kind of full theory.
So the full theory for the
sigma model is the following--
kinetic term, mass
term, interaction term.
And I can couple it
to something else
like a fermion to make
it more interesting,
with Yukawa couplings.
And this theory has an SU2 left
cross SU2 right symmetry, where
I take psi left to L psi left,
psi right to R psi right.
And I also transform
pi to L pi R dagger.
And if you think of these
L's and these R's, you
should think of them as
something with some generators.
So L would have something like
that, with tau left generators,
and then some parameters alpha
L. If I worked infinitesimally
in those parameters, then
if I expanded this out,
this would give a
linear transformation
to the sigma and the pi vector.
That's what it's meant,
that it's linear--
so a linear infinitesimal
transformation to pi and sigma.
So this theory has
spontaneous symmetry breaking.
And if we write out the
potential by taking the traces,
and we can write
in a way that makes
that obvious by
completing the square.
And we can always throw
away irrelevant constants
when we do that.
So we get something like that.
So the minimum is shifted.
And so if we want to
shift ourselves over
to describe perturbations
around that vacuum,
then we can do that.
So let this guy have a
VEV, which I'll call curly
V, square root mu
squared over lambda.
Pi vector field has
no VEV, because we
want to maintain
the vector symmetry.
And we talk about
a shifted field,
which describes
perturbations around the VEV
when we do quantum field
theory in the sigma twiddle.
And then we write our Lagrangian
in terms of the sigma twiddle,
just by making a
change of variable.
And that makes clear
who's getting masses
when we expand
around that vacuum
and who's remaining massless.
And of course, the Goldstones
are remaining massless,
and the Goldstones, by
clever choice of notation,
are called Pi.
Let's see if I can
squeeze it all in here.
This is something they tell you
in Professor 101 never to do,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
Since if you can't
read something,
you can always look at
my notes when I them.
So I didn't write all the
fermion notes down again,
but I could do the field
redefinition in those modes
as well, the shift
in those terms.
And the vector subgroup,
which remains unbroken,
is no transformation for
sigma and the Pi field
has left equal to right, so
we just get some matrix V
on both sides.
And if we look at the
Lagrangian that we have,
then we can identify the
masses of various things
at tree level.
And I didn't write
down the fermion part,
but the fermion gets mass 2
from the [INAUDIBLE] coupling,
just like in the standard model.
And the Pi, of course,
remain massless.
And the idea of thinking about
this is an effective theory
is that we can take
these to be large.
And then there's
a clear separation
between low-energy
degrees of freedom
and heavy degrees of freedom.
So if we want to describe
this with an effective theory,
we would like to describe
the physics of the pions
without worrying too much
about the sigma and the psi.
So we could do that just by
thinking about this Lagrangian,
but it turns out that you
can make field redefinitions
and think about using
different formulations which
are entirely equivalent.
And some of those are more
useful than this linear sigma
model.
So we're thinking here
of field redefinitions
as an organizational tool.
So you'll see what I mean
when we go through this.
So let's consider some
different choices.
So there's something called the
"square root representation."
So I just make a field
redefinition like that--
involves a square root.
And if I expand it, it
starts a sigma twiddle,
and then it goes a
bunch of other terms.
So it's certainly
within the realm
of the things that are allowed
by our field redefinition
theorem.
And then I also talk about
making a field redefinition
for the Pi as well.
And again, this is
Pi plus other terms.
So in this square
root representation,
we're going over to
these fields S and psi.
So these are our new fields.
So we can make that
change of variable
and just write out our
linear sigma model again.
And it's the same theory,
it's just field redefined.
And it looks kind of Godawful,
but it's more beautiful
than it looks.
So that's something you don't
want to do more than once.
So that's one
possible way that we
could deal with the
effective theory,
is in terms of these
variables, S and phi.
Let me write down a
couple other ways,
and then we'll talk about
which we might pick.
So there's something called the
"exponential representation,"
also very common.
These are very common
in the literature,
where instead of using S
and phi, we use S and sigma.
So we take our original
fields, and we rewrite it
as v plus S times sigma.
And then we think of sigma
as the exponential, and hence
the name, of our
fundamental Goldstone field.
So this is not the same Pi.
It's some Pi prime, if you like.
But I'm going to drop the prime.
So you write everything
in terms of S and sigma,
and you keep in mind that
inside the sigma is the Pi.
So the S part at the
beginning is the same.
And this guy's a little
bit nicer to write down.
So the terms that are
pure S remain the same,
so S cubed, S 4th.
Since there's no funny
square roots in our field
redefinition, things
are a little simpler.
So that's, again, an equivalent
version of the sigma model,
just using different fields.
Everything I can calculate
in the original sigma model,
I can calculate these
formulations as well.
And the final one is
going to be different.
And that's the non-linearity
chiral Lagrangian.
And what I'm going to
do to get there is I'm
just going to drop
the things that
have mass from my previous
theory, which are S and psi.
So I take this
exponential representation
of the sigma model.
These guys are massive.
I think about-- well, I
integrate them out explicitly.
In this case, what we're
doing here, which is not QCD,
we can do that,
just remove them.
That amounts to the lowest
order, just dropping them.
And then we have just the
thing involving the pion,
which is just very simple--
that.
So this is a viable
thing for low energies.
The first three actions that
we wrote down are identical.
They're just field redefined
versions of each other.
They're really
equivalent theories.
And this final one,
L chi, is equivalent
for low-energy
phenomenology of the pions.
So the first three are actually
equivalent to the last one
if we restrict ourselves
to low-energy interactions.
So in order to see that,
let's do an example
where we calculate something.
Let's think about calculating
Pi plus Pi 0 goes to Pi plus Pi
0, so scattering of
Goldstone bosons.
And q will be the
momentum transfer.
So in kind of an
obvious notation,
it's the difference between
the final and the initial,
or the initial and the
final for the charge guy
or the neutral guy.
And there's two types of
diagrams that can come in.
You could have a direct
scattering diagram
or you could have
an exchange diagram.
so this is Pi plus coupling
to either the sigma or the S,
depending on which
representation we're using.
And then the Pi 0 is down here.
And I want to take these,
and I want to expand.
And I'm going to expand in
q squared over v squared.
That's what I'm going
to mean by "low energy".
v was setting the
scale of the masses.
So let's see how that works
out in the different cases.
If I do it in the
linear case, and I
have both of these
types of contributions,
this guy just gives me
some symmetry factor,
which is 2 minus 2i lambda.
This guy as a propagator, square
root looks very different.
And it turns out
in the square root,
that you can find out that
this guy is order q to the 4th,
so we won't even write it down.
Exponential-- this guy
is again ditto and ditto,
and then I don't have room,
but I'll put it up here.
In the nonlinear, we don't
even have that diagram
because we just dropped it.
And if I take this line,
which is the only one that
looks different, I can combine
these two terms together.
And once I do that, then I
realize that this is also
giving the same answer.
So just rearrange it, put
in the relation between mass
and coupling and VEV, which
looks like that, and expand.
And you get i q squared
over v squared as well.
So if I stop at order
q squared, all versions
give the same thing.
The linear and the square
root were equivalent.
The linear, the square
root, and the exponential
are just different
versions of the same thing.
And all that's changed by
making the field redefinition
is how I think about
these two diagrams.
In the linear, the
leading order term is not
coming from just
this diagram, it's
also coming from that diagram.
And it's actually coming
from a cancellation
between those diagrams.
In the square root and
exponential representation,
this diagram alone gives
the leading order term
and this diagram
gives higher order
terms, which is kind
of what you want
if you want to think about
these heavy particles
as something that is giving
high-order corrections.
So that can depend on
exactly how you formulate it.
And from the point of
view of just keeping
the low-energy
degree of freedom,
the nonlinear just gives
you immediately the answer
from very simple Lagrangian.
Of course, it was just the
exponential with something
dropped.
So from the point of view
of doing calculations,
the linear version here is the
one that you don't want to use,
because there's cancellations
between diagrams
that you have to figure out.
And those cancellations
actually affect
what you call "leading
order," because leading
order for this calculation
is order q squared,
and you don't see that until
there's that cancellation
that's taken effect.
So it's very hard to
formulate a power accounting
for the linear theory
for that reason.
But if any of these
nonlinear theories
we could formulate
a power accounting,
then everything is
nice and beautiful.
So what happens is that
because of chiral symmetry,
we have derivative couplings.
And in the linear
version, we don't
see that until we cancel terms.
So if you like, if
you think about that
as a property of the symmetry,
you'd like to make it explicit,
and the other
representations do that.
The version that's
most convenient
is the non-linear guy,
since it's the simplest.
And we just think
about it, forgetting
about the heavy stuff.
And it's what we really want for
our bottom-up effective theory
because it only has
the low energy sigma
field, which has a
pion in it, and it
has the derivative couplings.
If you look at how
the symmetry works,
which I didn't talk
about when I wrote down
all the different
versions, S is for singlet.
That's what's behind the name
S, so it doesn't transform.
Sigma transforms on
both sides with an L
on the left and an R
dagger on the right.
And that comes from
looking back, noting
that S doesn't transform,
and looking back
at how the Pi field transformed.
It's just exactly that way.
Now, if you write out the sigma,
which is transforming linearly,
as the exponential
of i tau dot Pi,
and if I put it in a
convenient normalization, which
is the VEV, or the v,
then you can work out
from this transformation
how the Pi field transforms.
And it transforms
nonlinearly, and hence, that's
the name for--
that's where the
name comes from.
If you do the infinitesimal
version of the transformation,
and you work it out for
the Pi a field, which
is a-th component of the
vector, a being 1, 2, or 3,
part of the transformation
is simply a shift.
And then there are
additional pieces,
which are things that
you keep, that are
order pi squared and higher.
And that's those pi squared
and higher terms that they're
saying it's nonlinear.
This term here is what's telling
you it better be derivatively
coupled, because if it's
derivatively coupled,
if you have a derivative,
that kills this constant,
and that was something that was
hidden in our linear version
of the theory.
Now, we've constructed it
here from this kind of point
of view of integrating out.
So I said QCD, we
can integrate it out,
but all we care about is the
symmetry-breaking pattern.
So we wrote down a theory, which
is this linear sigma model,
had the same
symmetry-breaking pattern.
And we could remove the
heavy fields in that,
and then the low-energy
theory, I claim,
is the same one that you
would use to describe QCD,
because it's the same
symmetry-breaking pattern.
But that's kind of a
roundabout way of getting
to where we wanted to go.
And you'd really
like to just get
right to the chiral
Lagrangian from the start,
and you can do that.
So rather than going through
the linear sigma model,
we could also just directly
get to where we want to go.
And here's how you do that.
So go back to what the
symmetry-breaking pattern was
and figure out what
is it that we're
trying to do with the
low-energy effective theory.
So we have G that's broken
to H. The Goldstones are
transformations in the
coset, which is G/H.
And we'd like to
parameterize them.
And what we're doing
with this sigma field
is we're parameterizing
fluctuations
to take us around the coset.
AUDIENCE: I'm a little confused,
because if you don't expand
sigma, that Lagrangian has
still the full symmetry as you
do left, as you do right.
But it contains
the v, [INAUDIBLE]
parameter for the
rest of the symmetry.
That Lagrangian is presenting
the unbroken phase or--
IAIN STEWART: So
remember, I went over
to the shifted fields,
the sigma twiddle,
and then I was expanding
around the correct vacuum--
I mean, the one that's the
lowest energy vacuum, not
the unbroken.
I went from sigma--
I originally had sigma--
sorry.
Thank you for that.
So really, when I talked
about the linear version,
there was two versions
of the linear version.
There was the original
version where I wrote it down
in terms of sigma and Pi
vector, and then I went over
to sigma twiddle and Pi vector.
And when I went over
to sigma twiddle,
it was just a shift
where I shifted myself
to the proper vacuum.
So I'm really doing
the perturbation theory
in the linear here
about the proper vacuum.
And all the other
versions, I'm also
doing about that proper vacuum,
the lowest energy vacuum.
So there was a step at
the beginning, which
is the classic step for
spontaneous symmetry
breaking, which is--
in some sense, I had
to do that to get
started when I
went from the sigma
to the sigma twiddle field.
But you should
really think about it
as the sigma twiddle
field as being
field in this linear case.
That's a sigma twiddle there.
Other questions?
So how would we do this
construction of sigma
if we didn't know about
this linear sigma model
way of getting there?
So we have a
generator, G, which is
in L comma R. That's my notation
for the combined SU2 left
cross SU2 right, for example.
And that's going to be
broken down to something
that's in the vector sub-group,
which I'll denote like this--
V comma V. And then an
element of that we can call h.
And if we want to
parameterize the coset,
you can think that you
have a G left and a G right
in a kind of obvious notation.
And you want some kind of field
to parameterize fluctuations,
where we pull out the h.
So I'll call that "cascade."
So let's just think
about an example.
So say we had
something that looked
like this, which is some
set of generators that
is in the original
L comma R. And let
me insert in here 1
in the form of gR,
gR dagger, and then write it
as a product of generators
that looks like this.
So I just multiply
the various-- this guy
multiplies that guy, this
guy multiplies that guy.
So this guy here has the
same entries in both,
so that's in h.
This is in the v
comma v, which is h.
And this guy here,
this gR dagger,
is then the thing that's
parameterizing the cascade
field.
So this is a matrix that's
parameterizing the coset,
and transforms in
the way that we said.
So that's the idea behind
what the sigma field is doing.
Now, you can ask, well, that
just seems like one choice.
And I could think about
parameterizing the coset
in many different ways.
And that's true.
And there's actually
a nice formalism
that takes that into account.
So if you just talk about broken
generators, which I can call X,
then a very general definition
of what this cascade field is
is just an exponential involving
those broken generators,
and some fields to
describe the fluctuations,
and normalized in some way.
And this is due to Callan,
Coleman, Wess and Zamino.
So it's the CCWZ prescription
for parameterizing a coset.
And the point of
their prescription
is that you have choices
here for how you represent
the broken generators.
We start out with
left generators
and right generators,
and then you
go over to the
vector generators,
but what ones are broken?
Well, you could take
different linear combinations
that are broken.
And those would be
equally viable choices.
Doesn't have to be a group,
the broken generators,
so you can pick different
choices of this X.
And if we pick X, which
is the left generators,
that's actually
what gives us what
we were talking about before.
Because then we end up
parameterizing the cosets
by something as 1 in the
second entry, because we
don't have the right.
We're just saying pick the
left, the left are broken.
One possible choice, left
plus right is unbroken.
Then we end up with an
entry here, which is sigma.
That's our sigma.
And also, if you work
out the transformation,
how the sigma transforms,
you could reproduce--
you can also derive that sigma
goes to L, sigma R dagger.
But that's just one choice.
You could do other choices.
So for example, you could
pick X a to be tau left
a minus tau right a.
That's another possible choice.
And that would lead
to a different field,
but an equally valid
parameterization of the coset.
And this was actually
also popular.
It's something that people
usually denote by C.
I'm going to leave
further discussion of that
to your reading.
There's a very nice review
by Aneesh Manohar, where
he goes through some of
these things for CCSW,
and does a nice job of talking
about both of these in more
detail than I've done here.
So further discussion of this
point will be in your reading.
You can also look back at the
original paper, if you like.
But Aneesh has
distilled it nicely.
So any questions about that?
There's a way of thinking--
I'll just keep talking
until someone raises their--
there's a way of thinking
about field redefinitions,
even from this
low-energy point of view.
That's the key here.
And it has to do with
the freedom that you have
and how you
parameterize the coset.
So even if we're constructing
it from the bottom up,
there's different
representations.
In fact, Weinberg likes
the square root version
of parameterizing the coset.
Maybe he's the only person.
He has very good reasons
for being allowed
to stick with his
original results,
rather than the
exponential representation,
which everyone else seems
to favor, including me.
So if we go back to
talking about QCD,
then it's common to call
this curly V f over root 2.
1/2 is a decay constant.
And so the
conventions, then, are
the following-- at least one
possible choice of conventions.
There's some choice about
where you put the 2's, and then
everything else is fixed.
So this is one
possible common choice
for the exponential
representation.
And then that gives you
the chiral Lagrangian--
looks like that.
And if you expand this out, you
get the standard kinetic term
for the phi field.
That's what this
normalization factor does.
And then if you keep expanding,
you get some interaction terms
like this one, et cetera.
So there's four point
interactions in that Lagrangian
as well.
And that's because
we had a curved--
our coset is nontrivial.
So part of this story here
when you talk about symmetry
breaking has to
be about the fact
that symmetry is also
broken explicitly
in the standard model.
And so you have to add--
the Goldstones are
only pseudogoldstones.
You have to add a mass.
And the way you do that is
by doing a spurion analysis.
Remind you how that goes.
You write a mass term like
this, and to left and right.
The mass, you could say,
is just the diagonal matrix
of up and down for SU2.
And you could pretend, rather
than talking about things that
are violating the
symmetry like these guys,
you let the mass
transform and pretend
that you actually have
something that's invariant.
By pretending that
the mass transforms,
you're able-- if you
pretend the mass transforms
in the chiral theory--
of constructing
things that violate the
symmetry in the same way.
You construct invariance in
both theories with this kind
of transformation law.
And then when you go back
and fix them, and say no, no,
it doesn't transform,
it's really a fixed thing,
not a field that could
transform-- it's fixed,
the number--
then you violate the symmetry
explicitly in the same way
as up here.
It's a trick for how to
build things that are
covariant in a certain form.
So you could add the
variant operators
of the chiral Lagrangian.
This is a different
v, some parameter,
different than the curly
one we were talking about
earlier, which is now called f.
So this is the spurion story--
how to break symmetry explicitly
in a different theory,
the same way.
And if you expand
a quadratic order,
you get mass terms
for the pions.
I won't go through that.
But one kind of an
important thing about it
is that the mass is proportional
to v times the quark
mass, so v0, so the parameter
in the Lagrangian, linear
in the quark masses, quadratic
in the Goldstone mass.
You can also a
couple of currents.
And you can do a
similar type of analysis
with spurion-type transformation
analysis for the currents.
And I'm not going
to go through this
in any gory detail,
but just enough
to do what we need to do here.
So here's a left-handed fermion
current, standard model.
Could be coupling to the
W boson, for example.
And you could think of getting
J by taking a functional
derivative with respect to
a field that's left handed.
And then I can do the
same kind of thing,
where I think about this L and
let it transform, just like I
was letting the M transform.
So think about J as this
capital J times minus L.
And if I then think about
this L mu transforming,
I can build a chiral
Lagrangian, and then
use this formula to
construct the current
in the chiral Lagrangian.
So you couple a spurion
current, L mu a tau a,
and you, in this case,
in order to couple it,
you can let it transform like
a left-handed gauge field.
And then you get something
that's invariant.
So the transformation that
will make it invariant
is to think of it as a
left-hand gauge field.
So L mu goes to
L, L mu, L dagger.
And then that gives
you an invariant
in the original theory.
And then you build in a
variant of the x theory.
And so if you do
this, and you're
replacing, in your
chiral Lagrangian,
your partial derivative
by a covariate one,
it acts on the left
because that's where
the sigma is transforming.
And so it's an easy way
of building that in.
And you just get an i L
times the sigma on the left.
So you take everywhere you have
a derivative, you replace it
by this combination.
So we had two derivatives
in our chiral Lagrangian.
Expand it out, and
we can figure out
how to put it in the
left-handed spurion.
So the spurion is just
kind of a general way
of going from one
to the other just
by tracking symmetry breaking.
And you'll get
some more practice
with some of this
on your problem set.
So on your problem
set, what I've
asked you to do on problem set 2
is to do a one-loop calculation
in this chiral theory.
So you can really see that
this is a quantum field
theory, an effective
field theory,
not only a tree-level
mnemonic theory, but really
a field theory in
its own right where
you have to consider loops,
contractions, Wick's theorem.
Everything is the same as a real
quantum field theory should be.
It's an effective field theory
of certain degrees of freedom.
So you do a one-loop calculation
for the decay constant.
And there's two problems
in the problem set.
The first one is
fairly straightforward.
And then that's
the second problem.
That's all I'm asking you to do
because it's fairly involved.
It's like maybe two
normal problems.
So here's our chiral Lagrangian.
And we're going to count
in this chiral Lagrangian,
in terms of power counting,
partial squared as being order
v0 ab q.
That means we're going
to count p squared
as being order M pi squared.
That's going to
be our accounting.
And so we're going to expand
in these things as small
and something else
that is large.
And we'll figure out what the
large thing is in a minute.
So we do the expansion
like that, where something
is downstairs that has mass
dimensions and the things that
are upstairs are p squared
and then Pi squared.
So the type of
expansion we have here
is a combination of a derivative
expansion, although it's
a bit of a different derivative
expansion than before,
and an M q expansion,
simultaneously driven
expansion in these two things.
If we look at L0, then
it has things in it
like a propagator--
dashed line for the
scalar plan propagator.
It has four point interactions.
And if you look at
how those scale,
we could write out what
the Feynman rule is,
but if you look
at how they scale,
they go like p squared over
f squared, or M Pi squared
over f squared.
The p squared you
could put on shell,
and it would be M
Pi over f squared.
And you will actually
need this Lagrangian
and this Feynman rule
for your homework,
so let me tell you what it is.
And I'll leave it to you to
work out the Feynman rule.
So commutators,
there's a factor of 6.
And then there's
also a term that
would give four-point
scattering from the M2 term
in the Lagrangian.
So that also gives an M Pi
squared over f squared term,
and that looks like that.
So you could build up a
higher point function,
six-point function,
et cetera from
the leading-order Lagrangian
that has all this in it.
It has two parameters, f and v0.
So what about loops?
And what about this?
What is this scale lambda chi?
So the type of loops that
you can have if you have
a four-point interaction, and
just draw a solid line since
it's easier than
drawing dashed lines--
think of all these as dashed.
So there's cross diagrams as
well as the original diagram.
This is not the
calculation I'm asking
you to do in the homework.
If we thought about our example
of Pi plus Pi 0 scattering,
then we could contract up
Pi plus and Pi 0 fields,
and we could have a loop
that looks like that.
And in order for our
theory to be unitary,
we have to think that
these loops make sense,
because there's cutting
rules, and all that story
should go over for this
quantum field theory.
And it does.
And that means that if you like
the imaginary part of this loop
is needed, and you can't
get the imaginary part
without the real
part, so we have
to also think that
the real part is
a physically meaningful thing.
And so we can go
ahead and compute it,
and figure out what's going on.
So there's derivative couplings
that go like f squared, 1
over p squared over f squared.
L is the loop momenta.
Primes are the final.
Unprimes are the initial.
You can parameterize
it however you like.
I'm using here dimensional
regularization.
I like to dimensional
regularization, and so do you.
Dimensional regularization
here preserves chiral symmetry,
which is something that
we want to preserve.
And I'll tell you
a little later what
would have happened if we'd
done this with a cut-off.
So if you do this calculation,
just calculate those guys,
you get terms that
go like p to the 4th.
You get terms that go like
p squared, M Pi squared,
terms that go like
M Pi to the 4th.
You get a 4 Pi,
because it's a loop,
and then you get
an f to the 4th,
because there's
four factors of f.
So what this behaves
like, it's p squared
or M pi squared over
f squared, which
was our tree-level, four-point
function, times something
that's causing suppression,
which is p squared
or M Pi squared
over 4 Pi f squared.
So the loop is actually
down by a factor of p
squared over 4 Pi
f, all squared.
So just by explicit calculation
and not breaking the symmetry,
we see that loops are suppressed
by p squared over lambda chi
squared, where lambda chi
here is defined to be 4 Pi f.
So the 4 Pi is important
because f is like 130 GeV,
and you need this 4 Pi in
order to have some range
for your chiral expansion.
So if you plug in
numbers, depending
on your conventions
for f-- and there's
a couple of common conventions.
You could get numbers that
are like 1.6 or 1.2 GeV, so
some scale of order a GeV.
On general grounds,
you could also
ask the question, if
I just think about it
from the effective
theory, what is
a reasonable scale
for the denominator,
for this lambda chi?
Remember, you're going to
have to construct higher order
operators as well.
And so you need to
figure out what's
the right scale for the
suppression of those higher
order operators.
And if you did it
on physical grounds,
than what you'd expect
the lambda chi to be
is about the mass of the rho.
Because that's the lowest
energy hadron that you've
left out of this chiral theory.
You might expect
lambda chi's of order M
rho, which is sort of 770 MeV.
And so you can't really say
whether it's 770 or 1.2,
because the difference
between those,
although important
numerically, is not
within the realm of the
kind of factor 2-ish meaning
of these twiddle symbols.
So these twiddle symbols mean
"parametrically of order."
Then there's two
symbols-- there's
much greater than or twiddle.
"Twiddle" means factor of 2-ish.
"Much greater" means
parametrically [INAUDIBLE]
or much less than.
And just with those two
symbols, there's some freedom.
These are different ways of
doing an estimate for what
lambda chi are, just saying
that there is that freedom,
and you have to do
the full calculation
in a particular channel
to really figure out--
or a particular piece
of phenomenology--
what the lambda is.
Extract it from
data if you like.
So that is likely a
good place to stop.
And next time, we'll
talk a little bit more
about these loops.
And we'll talk
about what happens
to these loops in the power
counting theorem that you have,
that organizes all
diagrams in this theory,
and tells you what you have
to do if you want to construct
the Lagrangian order by order--
how you deal with when
to put in the loops,
when to put in
the counter terms.
We'll talk about those
things next time.